she's very pale she's very uh Netherland
shaped you know what I'm saying fish
like [__] Amazon
blonde hair no [__] features [__]
content I'd like to say the the most
insulting part of this
is I have red hair
they're calling me a blonde I have red
hair you know if I started making fun of
a black woman's skin color and her
features
I would be canceled tomorrow why is it
perfectly okay for her to make fun of my
European features I don't want to insult
her look
although there's plenty there's plenty
of
could I could but but that's not that's
not how I really go about things right I
know I call fat women fat but that's
just fact that's just fat
[Music]